The last time we were together,
you were growing a garden.
How is the garden?
Well, the garden is garbage.
It was great last year.
And then I got victimized
by a pack of raccoons.
There were six raccoons 'cause I have my cameras,
and I was like, "What is going on?"
'Cause I would go outside in the morning to water my garden
and there would just be things, plants all over the place.
Holes, dirt everywhere.
I was like, "What happened in here?"
It looked like a human being came
and dug everything out.
And I looked at my cameras and it was six huge raccoons
flying across the lawn, going to the beds
and they didn't even eat the vegetables.
That was the worst part.
They just ransacked it for pleasure?
Yeah, well, I dunno what their end game is
and I'm still trying to figure it out.
They just threw away
all these beautiful organic hand grown vegetables
and they just didn't eat them.
And I'm assuming they buried
some valuables or something in there.
Well, you tell those raccoons
that they better stay away from your garden
or I'm gonna come and kick their, you know what's!
Well, I will and I'm sure they will listen to me
but I am sprouting sprouts right now.
I am doing seedlings.
I am not giving a up.
I will prevail.
Don't give up.
And maybe a little fencing.
Oh, you think I haven't thought of fencing.
(Drew laughs)
I put fence in the beds around the edges
and I covered it in sheets
and bird wires.
They ripped it all out.
They're very strong.
Now I would love to ask you, which is so crazy.
This is the third time before we get to Dollface.
This is the third time we've done this show together
and I never talked to you about doing Sex and the City.
Oh my God.
I love you in Sex and the City.
Thank you.
I love you in that episode so much.
What was it like, give me fly on the wall?
What was that like?
Well, it was amazing.
First of all, I was, I think 13, maybe 14.
Oh God, look.
Look at the look on your face.
I was a fetus.
I didn't know what the show was.
My mom and I took a cab from Penn station to my audition.
I was like, "This is a weird show.
It has a word sex in it.
I don't know, whatever."
And when it was time for the show to air,
we didn't have cable.
So my mom got cable and all my little girl friends came over
with their moms to watch the show.
And if you remember
that this is one of the most messed up episodes
of Sex and the City.
Because my mom ran to turn it off.
Everyone's mom was like, "Oh."
It was crazy.
But at the time I just thought it was cool
and doing some TV show that I had never heard of.
And I got to wear pretty outfits and have my hair done.
And everyone was really nice to me.
And be so sassy, yes.
And Michael Patrick King was there
who I later worked for who created Two Broke Girls.
Yes.
So that was interesting.
(audience claps)
Full circle.
I mean, that is an origin story for sure.
Okay, tell me about Dollface.
This is the second season of this show.
What is it about Dollface that speaks to you
or that you get to do differently?
Well, I am a real sucker for feel good stuff.
I've done a lot of fun, amazing things
but there is just something about the warmth
and coziness of this show.
And the cast is just the most incredible group of women.
And I love them so much.
Brenda Song is one of my best friends in the world
and that chemistry really translates.
I mean, you can't fake that kind of thing.
So that's really fun for people to watch.
And yeah, season one left off with my character Jules,
ruining someone's wedding
and then exposing Brenda Song's character,
Madison's boyfriend as being the husband of my boss.
So I blew everything up essentially.
And this season begins with me going into the office
for the first time after the pandemic,
assuming that I'm going to be fired,
but instead I get promoted.
(audience cheers)
(Kat laughs)
Well, if anybody tries to mess with your wedding
you call me and I will meet them in a dark alley
at a very late hour and I will take them down.
I will give them the raccoon treatment.
Thank you so much.
I was thinking of having a raccoon officiate.
So we'll see how that goes.
Thank you so much, Kat.
I love you so much.
Season two of Dollface is available now on Hulu.
And we will be right back.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪